[Music]
that the holy prophet Muhammad sallallah
alaihi wasallam was mentioned by name in
the
Bible in fact the the the form Muhammad
is impossible in Hebrew it violates
there's no possible verbal form not
P now Muslims have had 14 centuries to
find their best strongest examples of
prophecies about
Muhammad we've heard this for years and
in Christian circles and in Jewish
circles this is a point of laughter for
us I am co-authoring a book with two
other uh researchers
[Music]
I've been working on a book for the last
3 years which is going to show from
Genesis to Malachi how all of this fits
together and it's better than the New
Testament attempts uh of proving
prophecies for Jesus
[Music]